six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go to our next caller
calling in from the seven one seven area
code caller in seven one seven what's
your name where you're calling from and
what's on your mind today
[Music]
okay did you say well your volume is a
little low did you say Kelvin yeah yep
Kelvin okay good
Calvin got it all right go ahead Kelvin
and speak up if you can well uh Wow it
might sound a little disturbing but I've
been waiting for this moment for like a
year okay I mean no mar-a-lago
is like sitting in the path of a huge
hurricane I read about this I read about
this yeah mar-a-lago is in the path of
hurricane Emma and people on Twitter are
going completely bonkers yeah okay but
so then what what do you want it to be
destroyed well no because like like
people are talking about how we're
running out of money for a federal
emergency beam-up yeah yeah our funds
and like if something were to happen
tomorrow lago would there be like a
sudden change of heart I see what you're
saying
yeah yeah of course there would be I
mean listen we've got years of
experience from these Republicans who
when it's funding for some disaster that
doesn't affect them well I'm not so sure
and when it's for their state then all
of a sudden they need the money although
Trump has been you know his decision
with the debt ceiling partially was
connected to making sure that there is
hurricane relief funding so it might not
be Trump as the hypocrite personally in
this particular case but you know it's
his property so like he might actually
like we will use this as leverage to
twist the arms oh all right Calvin I
think we're having a connection issue I
do appreciate the call and we will see
what happens tomorrow Lago you never
know anything could happen